ho sbagliato ad avviare la live prima
cambiare la copertina
io l'ho avviata a prescindere va bene
non fa niente schifo non sono capace
sono capaci a farlo youtuber devo fare
il pescivendolo io ho sbagliato tutto da
di hawes vagliato tutto signori pro
grazie di essere qui anche oggi ciao
amici
non so se mi sentite se mi vedete non lo
so aspetto che devo cambiarla miniatura
si sente e si sente bene come state
amici
mettiamo in natura parte 2 bene allora
allora ciao amici allora la qualità come
scusami ok dovrebbe essere tutto a posto
in teoria
ditemi se vedete sentite fate cose
giusto amici miei
oggi tutti navali in isole shaun però
non so se l'avete visto non so se live
del volume alto scusatemi scusatemi
volume alto spetta prova brava proprio
proprio arco demonio sarà alto volume
che cazzo è successo era altissimo
vi sentite bene adesso era altissimo
volume cosa è successo era era era stava
esplodendo la cassa adesso come come
meglio è
scusate mi sono un po non sono capaci a
farlo io no e che ho fatto delle
modifiche oggi perché ho aumentato
aumentato la qualità dei video in teoria
perché adesso si dovrebbero vedere molto
meglio e non le live e video normali
quindi niente ho fatto fatto due tre
modifiche spero vada tutto bene
e vabbè alla qualità massima e bassa che
aveva modificato tre prove ho fatto
delle modifiche quindi perdonatemi se ci
sono dei problemi
datemi un secondo
second ho cambiato 23 robe adesso
scusatemi se però fatto dei cambiamenti
mi servono per i video normali in teoria
ci dovrei essere riuscito ok adesso
dovreste vedere che lo meglio tra un po
un pelo meglio bene non so se avete
visto il video di marco di marco quello
del su pokémon pokémon di marco io
volevo volevo vederli insieme regala vi
prego prima iniziare prima di cominciare
con alison e shawn vi prego parliamo di
marco perché è una roba incredibile
quello quello di tokyo non esatta cioè
non avete idea di che cos'era ciao
ragazzi
iniziamo scusatemi se un po amin chiama
ho fatto le modifiche del race tour
verso sia stato tutto qualità il video
di marco lo vediamo una volta poi giuro
iniziamo però voglio vederlo
assolutamente di pubblico insieme
together
se però questo video è geniale io spero
i diodi che abbiate visto tutti se non
l'avete visto io l'ho visto mille volte
però le coop
[Musica]
state fatta benissimo sta parte
grazie per lui non è mio padre che era
apprezzato precisare che secondarie
ma è il palermo
ma ci siano già finito era mica si no
non mi ha dato veramente uno schiaffo
trademark dire il vero avevo questo
giocattolino quando ero piccolo e molto
simile mamma mia ma valenti 460 grande
in questa casa dimenticando
charles fort entrato linea
[Musica]
quella merda merda mi che ci rimango
male l'altro io vorrei farmi notare una
roba in st parte qua c'è una caccola nel
naso
non so se sì non so se la qualità della
della live e lo fa vedere proprio una
caccola nel naso ottimo ottico ottimo
veramente wow
questo quanto sembro io da 1 milione e
non sono assolutamente io però sembra
troppo io io pensavo di essere io poi mi
sono accorto che non ero io per farvi
capire quanto sono certo che siano tanto
quanto brutti costi capelli
una top screen della sua squadra
cambiare in sede cavaliere amici
immaginari senza bianchi dovetti quegli
anni così tanto che stava parte quello
che preferisco pesce mons
vabbè comunque ditemi se non è
ditemi se non è la il video più ma più
più bello che possa mai esistere
io non lo so penso sia la più bella
penso sia più bel video io abbia mai
visto nella mia vita vi giuro
mai visto un video così grazie inatteso
per la donazione grazie mille niente
iniziamo con alison mi dispiace che che
è successo ma non mi si è raffreddata da
likes to date mi dispiace veramente un
sacco che per chi non l'ha visto sto
video ragazzi in marco è un malato
mentale non può montare così non può
montare c'è è veramente pazzo è
veramente pazzo però va bene grazie
franchi emergere leonida sebastian live
in the ninja e alex e vabbè dai
cominciamo con ali io volevo vedere
questa cosa perché sarà la ventesima
volta in tutta la giornata e melo
riguardo anche se uscito ieri è il video
della vita senza se e senza ma ledko
allora non so se vi ricordate da quando
quando avevamo giocato l'ultima volta
eravamo rimasti che dovevo trovare devo
trovare il medic it
alla fine ho scoperto che il medic it
dove li prendono all'inizio no prima è
visto gioco tu devi prendere i futuri
medici per curarti il problema è che
devi avere il caso per fabbricarli ok
quindi c'è stato un dibattito
incredibile sulla e ma dovevi prenderlo
all'inizio poi non l'hai preso e io
dicevo ma scusa mente se io mi dimentico
il foglio perché vi prende un foglio per
crearti inediti di menti il foglio
all'inizio come minchia fai poi a
curarti in teoria non ti curi più
wow ottimo design di gioco visto che io
non l'ho preso però ho scoperto che ci
sono altri mediche poi c'è poi prendere
altri fogli che trovi in giro e prendi
altri medici molto bene quindi ci sono
altri medici non ce l'ha solo quello
grazie a dio perché sono nero nella
cassetta grazie ciao fini bat sempre
mica sei tu sei stata presente sempre
miss a number one
immagino di tutte le live bacino martyna
ciao roby ciao nicola let's go dove
rimasi minchia gomiti pazzoide malato
comunque è stato re nel medikit so anche
dove si trova il medico adesso so anche
dove si trova il problema è che ci devo
arrivare per arrivarci deve avere una
torcia a ioni che sarebbe una specie di
[Musica]
perciò è una specie di fiamma ossidrica
poi di rete me cojoni ci avete pure
ragione è solo che non so dove si trovi
da la fiamma ossidrica appena la trovo
se dio vuole che la trovo posso prendere
medikit livello dove so dove si trova
quale può che avevano scelto io se l'ex
coi viola zigo pikachu il video è
fantastico marco è pazzo c'è lui monta i
video così e non dorme per farlo penso
che non abbia dormito mi pare per tipo
12 giorni io ho scelto pokémon le scopi
cacio perché non so perché in realtà
anche gli piace molto però ho scelto
pikachu poi troppo farò anche io il mio
rido su pokémon arriverà la settimana
prossima i telefoni grazie ad un
preparazione
eravamo rimasti che c'era lì e che mi
aveva incrociato da dietro ma fa niente
perché tanto non avevo neanche salvato
quindi let's go fantastico let's go
alien non mi dicono che sta offrendo un
codice etico
no non trovo un cazzo di rispetto ha
sentito il codice di accesso dovrebbe
essere no
l'ho trovato non l'ho trovato un ragazzo
a chi si è bloccato ma trova la tessera
accensione dottor marmor lei bob marley
ok tessera l'accesso avessero accesso
dove l'attesa amica non l'avevo fatta
just a parte non mi ricordo
semplicemente dodo dove sono le cose o
che c'è un razzo non dovevo trovare
nient'altro qua siam sicuri
diamo no ok ho fatto io mi quello che
doveva trovare un codice una roba del
genere forse mi sbaglio io
vabbè è il fatto che devo trovare st
maledetta torcia a me go ioni appena la
trovo trova anche il medico
il problema è che devo arrivare a quel
punto lì con questo sputo di vita che ho
in basso a sinistra mi deve passare per
tutto il gioco perché c'è finché non
trovo la torcia perché sono non medikit
molto bene e tra un po c'è almeno adesso
c'è all in in realtà non me lo ricordavo
bob marley è veramente un attore
veramente sul serio c'è una tresca bob
marley a una baracca ma ceo ecco questo
dicono se io dico qui se io faccio così
e quindi si sente di beep beep beep e
poi c'è il puntino di alieno ma alieni
individua perché sente i vip è una
domanda cioè serio perché non so se
tenerlo fuori
non so se tenerlo fuori quindi io lo
tengo fuori però è giusto dilemma
incredibile in questo caso non devo
tenerlo fuori perché fa bip bip e attira
da li attira libero tra l'altro non ha
idea di dove sia finito dove mickey è
finito scura mi e scomparso dal mondo
eccolo mali adesso perfetto arrivare
qualcosa che c'è la tensione ha accesso
eccola è un badge l'ho presa praga non
so dove sia linee l'ultima volta mi
aveva inglobato ed era qua mi doveva
chiara restare ma qua
17 02
lo ricordo solo perché me lo ricordavo
tipo di cure i chiudi per l'amor di gesù
cristo grazie bene ea linea portiamo già
andati più avanti dell'altra volta molto
bene solo che ricordiamoci che quel
maledetto passa nei condotti quindi non
stiamo proprio tranquilli dove è un cosa
per salvare grazie mille per avermelo
detto c'è un caso per salvare qualche
parte
salvate minchia stare veramente attento
perché so non voglio morire per gesù
cristo
mi sente il coso non attira lindsay
sicuro siete sicuri quindi io lo posso
tenere acceso no sto tornando indietro
sono scemo o è giusto no mica mi sono
perso in un metro quadrato vi sono solo
ci tabelle no non era giusto di quali
quale non c'è
non c'è cosa per chiudere la porta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
minchia come ha fatto entrare qua ho
chiuso la porta dietro come ha fatto
entrare nostro male scusatemi ciao amico
ciao milan so se passi la sua francesca
grazie di seguire la live
raga il radar attira ii n quindi non lo
attiviamo al radar salve io non attivo
nessuna da lei passiva da tranquillo ha
firmato la petizione pro savior internet
la fermata perché se ne sta bene è il
radar atti ryan non lo usiamo il radar
molti me non passare nei condotti con la
bava non ci passa tranquilli
[Musica]
l'alien non ti vede si sente solo
siete sicuri che questa cosa ragazzi
perché non ne sono completamente sicuri
colore state dicendo è sul melania mi
vede pure l'aria non mi vede quindi se
siete pazzi praga non so assolutamente
dove sia dietro che sempre ha cominciato
sempre cominciato devo salvare la
partita non me ne frega eccolo la sto
schifo di partita bene cosa farai ai
cinque di ieri iscritti e non me lo
posso dire ma una cosa molto grande che
stiamo definendo da un sacco di giorni
ai enza lì lui non ha invitato al posto
di trappole trovato nei condotti non
dovrebbe darmi molto bene allora non non
vede quindi confermato cali non vede
molto bene però sente quello sicuramente
non puoi entrare nei condotti
speriamo di dio
fuori molto bene
[Musica]
[ __ ] [ __ ] veloce quanto tempo
minchia che anzi di vivere
ma è in quel apri apri la porta perché
non si fosse stesso ricordandoci subito
che mi deve guidare serata l'obiettivo
con un vicolo più sapere al lavoratore
per i sottomarini
sì devo prendere delle cure per la mia
amica entra anche nei condotti ma
secondo me non entra nei condotti che
non mi ricorda è il cosa vuoi che faccia
ti devo dire di andare via
cerco di consentiva esci aprista porta
cosa vuoi che faccia per mandarlo via ma
scusami non c'è niente in può scacciare
a riempirla da zio aprista porta li
mortacci tua sorella battaglia
e come faccia mandarlo via ragazzi
spiega me lo faccio il giro posto va
bene secondo me non riesco a mandarlo
via però proviamoci
let's groove si può andare che lì sotto
la voce ripristina la corrente figurati
minchia che brutta cosa sto vedendo dove
andare di qua comunque molto bene quindi
lui non mi vedi se lui mi pare mi passa
davanti io posso stare anche fermo che
lui non mi sente c'è la logica dovrebbe
essere così parte che ho fatto il giro
opposto ma non sempre operavano prima
scusami o sono io scemo
ma siamo esattamente dove eravamo prima
quindi io mi sono perso a meno che non
sia un'altra stanza quale è esattamente
la stessa stanza di prima se io sto
fermo lui non mi vede e cieco buona
sapeurs l'arin sta lontano solo col
lanciafiamme che ovviamente ancora non
ho quindi no allora andiamo a dall'altra
parte via si è niente tutto uguale il
suo posto qui mi sono perso solo che
come facciamo andare avanti se c'è quel
demente che non mi apre la porta è
venuto venuto meno posso distrarlo
lanciamo lanciando qualcosa da qualche
parte qualsiasi cosa tipo ii che ci sono
entrato unica quindi ok
ecco demonio che è successo ci arriva da
una parte all'altra come niente vabbè a
di qua non ci sono ancora passato
vuoi importare nella programmazione
nuova giochi come venerdì 13 beh perché
non certo però la programmazione nuova e
molto diversa tavola di più quindi poi
vedrete munizioni revolver che fanno
sempre comodo e mi servirebbero delle
caramelle orco demonio
c'è un armadio sì
devo andare dall'altra mi ero mi ero
perso prima riuscito a perdermi un pirla
ma anche seguire la mappa devi
ripristinare la corrente scappare alla
volta sì avevo intuito il problema e
ripristinare la corrente
che ansia di vivere perché la sera ad
aumentarne giocata storia proprio adepti
wyss bravo fai casino che ne abbiamo
bisogno suo bambino si è spaccato un
ginocchio
dov'è il badge di sto mongoloide
ok ok sarà qua per forza ragazzo noi qua
non ho assolutamente idea di dove possa
essere il dato continua a trovare una
chitarra perfetto di suolo gualco
facciamo cantiamo le canzoni di alvaro
soler ad alien albano isole shaun vado
di equa dovrei guai che dovrebbe essere
qua è dovrebbe essere qua perché qua mi
indica questa zona qui quindi dovrebbe
essere qua la tessera trovate sarà
accesso al dottor ma ti dovrebbe essere
qui da qualche parte with farmela
cercano un attimo
ciao matteo porca vacca grazie ho
trovate ispeziona le sale ai pazienti ha
dato l ok importante che abbia giornata
grazie e matteo ciao a te molto gentile
per distrarlo accendi la radio usi il
razzo ok per quanto io sappia usare i
raid a doverti giocare grazie per queste
live grazie a te un bacino grazie in ora
come si curva giavazzi ho bisogno di la
risposta velocissima grazie come si
parli ad un microfono agli eventi sente
io sto facendo come si equipaggia il
razzo tipo in tempo zero grazie tempo
zero devo sapere questa cosa
adesso me lo dovete dire adesso il fork
caput vacca
[Musica]
vabbè vabbè la aprì la prima e per i
bimbi
la prima è che i bimbi e non mi aspetto
non posso correre che mi ha stancato
munch aspetta attimo che tratta con
qualcosa per salvare l'acqua no
deficienza questa volta lascio corro
facendo mio piccolo signori internet sei
un grande
guarda grazie mille ti ringrazio stary
teoria dovremmo esserci già riusciti ma
signori internet però però un aiuto in
più non fa sempre male cioè non fa mai
male valori console italiano quello un
piccolo problema mi pro grazie
l'occidente che insomma non usiamo come
si equipaggia il razzo magari per dopo
mi serve il razzo si equipaggia non si
equipaggia più inventario come minchia
equipaggio il fottutissimo razzo
il razzo come cup come se qui paghi
eccolo qua ne ho tre bene tante saperla
pisani suo gioco a cosa serve tranne che
per fare il figo niente io lo butto per
terra e quando mi arriva in faccia lo
butto perché il razzo di sta dietro
perfetto perfetto perfetto molto bene
voi no vado di sicuro più netto e dove
che era
ma dovevo ispezionare per bene tutte le
stanze tutta la stanza pellicola che la
chitarra e poi doveva aggiornarmi dai
cazzo è chic e problemi ragazzi chi non
vuole vedere un concetto di jim mollo
grandissimo g mollo jim morrison fermi
nei reparti si sblocca melo vostro
fottutissimo cosa perché viene sbloccato
adesso no dipende come gli gira
marcatura vicinissimo dov'è qui a destra
esattamente dov'era qui ok secondo voi
perchè non mi si tocca l'obiettivo se
prima nella sbloccato
burqa trottola il trucco secondo me
ragazzi andare esattamente dove lui
perché è esattamente il punto dove non
andrà dopo se non vedevo controllare
anche qua prima ho controllato non ho
raggiunto dei limiti per creare delle
cose c'è figure eccolo ma questo è un
bel normale va bene un importo
aggiornavi l'obiettivo cristo
bene devo cliccare la lavagna ok no
perché non mi sbloccava una sega bene
perché le cose in mezzo che giochiamo a
calcio ho firmato la petizione ti adora
i tuoi video sono una buona ragione per
la fa chi grazie mille marghe molto e
molto molto gentile 6 tanto gentile e lo
cliccata anche prima te lo giuro però
non la fuga grazie aver sussurrato
morley morri così adesso aliena belle
incassato molto più grazie mille davvero
mario glielo in finiamo su per il culo
sto razzo o se vogliono che ha fatto
pure tra giusto corridoio enorme che
indovina dove poi lui è lì esattamente
devo andare io perfetto perché ecco
infatti minchia se veniva dalla mia
parte io ero morto tre volte
tubo bomba
finalmente ho trovato un crafting 1 ecco
qui tra l'altro sta l'altro sarà tra la
sta roba qua se io salvo e alien sta
dietro il mio culo
cosa succede così chiedo si sa mai
complimenti per far cadere qualsiasi
cosa si ponga davanti alla tua strada
dal tuo obiettivo complimenti 0 quando
salgo posso permettermi di andare anche
un po più al cazzo duro tanto
chissenefrega
sono abbastanza
cosa c'è di qua sono abbastanza tutelato
dal fatto che si è schietto riparte
subito dopo cosa c'e di qua perché hanno
messo un condotto che è minuscolo tipo
così dovete porta sta roba
è una stanza chiusa no non è la stanza
chiuso abbastanza nella stanza che non
avevo scoperto un pezzo di metallo what
carino
permesso ai fucking hate aliens aliens
sax tranne you tranne you know you don't
sac vale nasce questa razza o minchia
quanto tempo operativo ad un razzo parco
demonio vabbé vabbé vabbé vabbé tanto
tanto come ho detto prima avevo salvato
quindi chi se ne frega però mica veloce
zio veloce miglia non è che stai a
pettinar le bambole a fare le torte c'è
un alieno grosso come tua nonna totò gli
accenti fa qualcosa per l'amore di gesù
cristo però vabbè
a girare il quad razza maturità giusta
stasi perché esattamente dove dove devo
andare io sempre e sempre dove devo
andare io sempre dove devo andare io
sempre dove devo andare
oggi questa breve tronto citate gigante
suo posto quanto grosso come mi open e
[Musica]
io passerò la mia vita da un armadietto
all'altro e sono fatti mi diverso io a
fare queste cose e divertente fare tutto
youtuber in questo modo messo un pò di
più bene giochiamo così
[Musica]
ehi
love aliens dublin ai want to believe
e mi sa che ti sbagli io mi sa che chi
mi sai che hai peccato la persona
sbagliata oggi non so non ho ormai ormai
mi rifiuto di seguire quella
quell'essere perché è inutile però il
problema è che non capisco dove devo
andare ispezionare tutto tutta la nave
ispezioni amo mentre c'è quello a fare
salve se mi dai una mano a trovare
questo [ __ ] coso tra il badge e un
laboratorio ma non devo tra le belle che
mi colava devo trovare un bel giorno
ricordavano le chine via il cazzo
grazie no adesso adesso proprio in
questo istante grazie mille molto
obiettivo importante che etici dov'è
andato tra è uscito di là insomma sei
uscito fai finta entra quanto tempo
[Applauso]
cos'è sta roba personale condivisa io
non li apro mai sti cosi perchè sono
inutili e rischiano di farti ammazzare
secondo me cioè che aumentano ci
spiegano un po cose della trama ma mi
sembra il momento o attenzione mister
robot in azione il 3 2 1 let's go è
enorme posso perché vede rompere le
palle profondo che basi qui
maronna lugar bene non andiamo dove
voglio andare io andiamo in altri posti
che dite voi devo trovare una stanza non
ho capito bene quale ma mi fido della
mia capacità se il piano ce la sto
facendo strane
va bene che ho l'ho detto soprattutto e
tric e trac e bombe a mano
ma va bene o no no tranquillo a posto
volevo dire e quindi se io li punto la
torcia in faccia teoria non dovrebbe
succedere niente a logica che bel
culetto zio
complimenti se mi dà il numero del tuo
estetista fidati che è chiamata gliela
faccio puoi andare da qualsiasi altra
parte non lui deve stare qua lui deve
stare quando che sono con noi in altri
bar in altri punti
lui deve stare qua te li fai due metri
non si arrivasse lui deve venire con me
ma io sono fermo dovrebbe toccare le
porte sapete la portano se per la porta
vai nella porta si è aperta sia aperta
la porta entra nella porta si sa
benissimo
l'intervista stai lì contempliamo il a
questa bellezza di nave grazie marco
molto gentile grazie sebastian grazie
gabriel sta facendo con le scatole
senti fufi minchia un ora e stato qua
fatto un raduno
sono fermo se è vero che ceco non mi
vede no
minchia ti ringrazio gesù cristo sono
stato fermo un'ora un'ora
cioè non ho parole rega un'ora sono
stato fermo cos'è sta roba qua c'è un
tastino attenzione a dove andare qua ok
è una l'ho chiusa devo chiedere pure
l'altra mi pare faccio il giro tanto
ormai non c'è più
son convinto di questa cosa che ho detto
minchia che anzi sto gioco porca vacca
no no no no no come possibile usarle e
non faccia casinò che qui c'è un mio
amico fuori che non è proprio il massimo
della compagnia però cerca penserà di
accesso o ai found it and iq sit com asp
e non ti vedo bene prendi una
tachipirina quando arrivi a casa devo
capire la tv se è affatto neanche mete
ricerca nasce anche lui da
gesù cristo belle stessa batte de
fonseca
devo capire un attimo dove si sposta lui
e se muoio mi incazzo visto che non ora
che non salvo così io ve la butto il
tratto c'è un punto di salvataggio qua
sai che vi dico faccio una cosa che
chiamero fare
andrò a salvare poi tornerò qui sempre
che lui non mi mangi la faccia nel
mentre file a tubo bola tubo bomba a
cosa serve cosa serve l'autobomba serve
per farci immagino faccia
spero faccia danno ad alien perché sono
fa dal nodali e non mi serve detto cosa
servono le armi sto giocano adesso me lo
spiegate perchè non servono a niente
la cosa che i robot per il rock per
stordire i robot con le armi non sa
brancaccio il primo c'è presidente nel
testo dice una porta solo clic in
sicilia porta lo so
problema che non c'è in tutte le porte
soprattutto non c'è in quelle che mi
servono tipo questa
ho dato nei condotti crede e nei
condotti ok saltato la partita no perché
non si sa mai
comunque come si creano gli oggetti cioè
io adesso posso creare st tubo bomba
però come li come si creano eccoli
ma basta cliccare col sinistro ma porca
vacca non sapevo e quindi boisi cioè nel
senso basta che trova qualcosa del made
chi teme lo creo easy e allora niente io
che me ne faccio autobomba tengo così
perin e farmi faccio 6.000 medikit no se
devo tutti gli oggetti ancora in
alimentari a 28 27 26
ma proviamo io devo chiudere le porte di
tutti questi no fuori uso cosa ti sei
perso tutto ogni secondo lee live deal
in isole shaun è qualcosa che ti perdi
fidati fratello fidati
poi c'era il tipo di auto e poi l'hanno
tolto perché faceva troppa paura al
gioco
ho un altro match ha in realtà potrei
anche sbattere tutto di chiudere sulle
finestre tanto devo andare dall'altra
parte però non è che mi piacerebbe
tornare indietro senza che quello mi
prenda la faccia però perché se muoio
arrivo più vicino al punto dove devo
andare
a me la cosa zio complimenti fashion
week
prego passi prima gli alieni poi le
signore poi io io sono una signora prima
gli alieni dopo di lei
madame madam mi avete mentito vede vede
benissimo gli ha acceso la torcia mi ha
visto allora ne ceco è scemo ma scusami
ma come ovunque chissenefrega tanto dal
punto di salvataggio alla fine più
vicino dove ero prima perfetto di data
l'ho fatto anche un po posta però c'è
solo da capire perché mi vede se non mi
ma gli occhi non c'è neanche non c'è non
vedere anche la luce ma scusa e dico
cosa che c'era niente di interessante
lancia la tubo bomba addosso non credo
che serva
[Musica]
scusatemi un secondo dimenticato di
strappare che ecco dritto molto bene
l'attore ha il click
ma va a cagare il click della porcia
vabbè adesso se scoreggia sono morto c'è
il click day ma vabbè dai regala stai
scherzando
poi lui che apra le porte poi vista la
vede tutto esplode esplode tutto dai
muri dovrebbe tirar testate al muro ogni
tre secondi no
amava il click da a d'orcia sentito va
bene non so
certo più perché la lampada che fa così
no la gente sente quello che vuole
va beh sono arrivati noemi sacra l'altro
alla via ora giusto non era giusto così
scusa adesso aprile sono t'ammazzo aprì
per l'amore di gesù a primi non mi
puntare solo a pini forse posso aprire
il dispositivo non voglio un uomo adre
morta come ci arrivo lì devo fare tutto
il giro a figure c'è il giro non è che
ci metto tanto però un passo in più sei
morto
dov'è che sta lo zio è da un po che non
lo vedo la cosa non mi piace
tornano dottor cool ma dopo può tornare
da lui ok posso correre non scherzavano
ancora un po meno è così io dico di più
di tanto che li fortis chiudi va bene
lascia aperto ci sono sì ma non urlare
equa l'ha presa bene sono mai questo
muore tra 3 2 1 no dov'è il salvataggio
più in acqua a gesù
due biglietti per gli anni dello show
grazie tolgo le mie cose poi potremo
andare a me tra l'altro di quelli cioè
se io fossi magrissimo potrei arrivare
dove lui va bene
come si entra lì ma qualcosa mi dice che
non ci voglio entrare lì va bene così
usa l'ascensore perseo kay ok quale
l'ascensore quale minchia e l'ascensore
scusa mente uso l'ascensore per scendere
all'ospedale
casarotto la stai vizi ostelli
tranquillissimo no no no no no no
schiaccia ok
vasculiti quanto tempo per madonna nel
3.020 gli ascensori fanno cagare fanno
cagare gli ascensori fanno cagare quello
di casa mia si chiude niente questo ci
mette un ora cristo ascensore per
dementi dammi la tessera yacht amori e
[ __ ]
accolgo le mie cose poi potremo andare
vabbè la per portarsi un po avanti cioè
stava sarebbe su sentite dai non mi
rompete le palle non mi rompete le palle
per cortesia e qualche brutto esso tizio
di ominoso e poi potremo andare se si
aprì
io se non ti chiudi già da mosca dove
non basta
dovevi schiacciare il tasto
vabbè raga vabbè ma che ma che è ma che
mai non ci giocava non mi ricordavo
neanche che si doveva andare in
ascensore figure se mi devo ricordare
che duplica speriamo il dio gesù cristo
pure che non arrivi qua e tron kit
medico e magari ma più che altro per
ritrovare il coso per fare il kit medico
però va beh spero non sia anche quindi
che la stanza di un metro un tonfo
elettrico questo non lo ricordo che
faceva cose che faceva schifo faceva
schifo
l'hilton fa elettrico cosa serve fatto
cosa fa o un po nfa sportello per aprire
i portelli tonfa elettrico e fallo tu
fai letta un falò tonfa
ma le parole
sì però rega dai un prete vi per il culo
ma questo ma mi chiama mamma mamma ma va
ma io non lo so vive ovunque non lo so
sembra un po john travolta a chi alien
cosa me ne faccio di un tonfa elettrico
a cosa serve il tom file e trino vi
prego stordisce gli androidi bailey boao
perché ne ho talmente tanti gli androidi
che non so proprio di stordire dal primo
complimenti grazie mille del tonfa
elettrico ripley ma io ti spacco la fama
cos'è il cristiana corrente cosa devo
fare qui cosa devo fare in questo posto
di un metro e mezzo dove esce alien
adesso parte che c'è il corso per
salvarla bleed hilton fra le tifoserie
per gli stitici hai ragione ci hai
ragione zio che poi d'altro non puoi
salvare in uno slot diverso di
salvataggi poi solo stover a scrivermi
salvataggi va bene cosa me ne faccio di
sto schifo
no seriamente non ho capito come vado
avanti
devo devos elettrizzare le porte a
partire quando farlo faccio lui mi sente
sono di uso hilton fa mi sente come come
dice un ragazzo ha fatto non si
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no seriamente mi dica cosa serve cosa
può fare in statista o m 20 neanche 10
metri per 10 distanza e cosa faccio
niente belle gambe sensi complimenti
apc abbiamo dei problemi secondo queste
scemo
questo non fa ma non ho fatto niente ma
pure con non faccio niente e faccio
casino miniere non faccio niente viene
allora [ __ ] ma giocato ma scusami
se con sepe tutela e ti stimo molto e
vorrei vivere ti presto grazie mille del
messaggio ma ho trovato una porta che
prima non c'era adesso c'è chi sa perché
ci vuole troppa a il talk show aveva
aperto la porta il tonfo aveva aperto la
porta
ottima seguo sempre e sono quasi tutte
le liti stimo molto grazie mille zia
bacini razziale per la nazione gta lo
porto molto presto grazie matteo re e
grazie a stage è pali di seghe che non
so non avevo capito che il tolfa aveva
aperto la porta
se gli spari
ma perché non è brutto è il tom fa
proprio un nome che fa ridere cene se
tomtom fa norma che si chiama tom fa non
può far non far non fa niente cosa devo
fare qua a dove infilare le devo
refrigerato le cose prefiggete
refrigerio ma ne manca uno comunque
tutto questo chalayan dall'altra parte
della porta
filati nell'angolo e stai nell'angolo
ora è fridge erato adesso li si è aperta
la porta deve andare a prendere il
refrigeratore la e infilarlo fa molto
bene nel mentre che alien sta dall'altra
parte
speriamo che non esca adesso
gesù mi vuole bene
gesù mi vuole benissimo eccolo l'ho
preso
salve la vedo male però non è problema
mio
quanta gente che è successo ma per
questi sono morti per quale motivo
scusatemi che comunque tutta gente
fredda in questo posto nessuno che mi
parlò mettiamo il refrigeratore qua
allora attivati valico che quindi quella
stanza si è attivata adesso posso
entrare anche lì cosa ci faccio limbo
bravi ragazzi lavai voi dovete guardarla
rigorosamente con le cuffie schermo
intero e luce spenta e tutto volume
ovviamente io la luce accesa dalle
cuffie e non sono tutto io tutto il
contrario invece il cablaggio meno
infilo nell'ano cosa da fare qua da
parte contemplare i bellissimi cadaveri
che mi interessano contro lamentale
trova trova un kit medico ha magari si è
aperto ad usare il recap la jones che
ancora non ho capito come funziona
salvare i cablaggi accesso al condotto
che
se ne frega della politica sarà accesso
ai condotto va in fondo una certa link
ufficiale superiore
devo scoprire che tengono tutto il suo
ufficio attento ai condotti sul soffitto
si si si era tranquillo tanto lo sento
che sta camminando di sopra come se
volesse pestare i capelli
chissenefrega chissenefrega space devo
spegnere anche io la luce non mi vedete
ragazzi io spengo mentato mica uguale
tranqui sono solo a casa quindi io si
spengono cielo mi vedete adesso vi
faccio vedere come si vede si spengo le
luci mi vedete però che sono buio si
becca ecco
si vede un cazzo quindi io devo tenerla
accesa però devo ammettere che la che fa
veramente un sacco caja continuo per un
attimo così mia che brutta mientes
ambiance ambiente shaun sono caduto dal
condotto come alien
mi sento un figo cerca informazioni si
certo di qua dietro l'armadio allora
deve uscire la ragazza e mi più
malissimo per carità aggiunge su cristo
scendiamo minchia che brutta cosa
certo che siete tutti a sociali in
questo posto colla perché mai uno così
budella semmai non col igei gene area
igiene area e o nell'area age però mi
dice deve ricerche informazioni
nell'ufficio di lynggaard non ho idea di
dove sia l'ufficio di libri c'è un
distributore di made chi no
comunque i medici di poi solo fabbricare
non te li puoi fare mi sa che è arrivato
lo zio pro capite
ok
ma se sei andato avanti in un vai avanti
mi sono preso malissimo non è stato un
vero e proprio jobs kermanshah eravamo
veramente indovina da che parte andato
allo zero proprio dov'ero io tanto va bè
web con gli iniettori sicuri non credo
credo che gli iniettori servono per fare
le cure non per curarsi che sarebbe
quasi cassa acustica bomba fumogena tubo
con button faretti a scusato con ricordi
sempre che qua
dove marco quando serve che tira un
cartone da lì me lo chiedo anch'io
me lo chiedo anche io
mi piace questa cosa che per un secondo
di eventuali nei condotti prima o poi
basta allora staff galli dove devo
trovare la roba di king hard se io vado
di qua senior medica senior i senior
america chamber componente b ragazze
preso mi piace io devo andare cominciato
di continuo perché sono con l'affare
miss pascal deretano motore v8 condivisa
opportunità a 2.137 nel 2100 poche
successo ufficiale medico superiore
stazione sebasto vuoi un cervello
poi questo mette a verbale che ho subito
delle costrizioni riguardo il paziente
zero che è in fin di vita
ransom il capo operativo della sic saint
louis
matteo ha fatto delle minacce ora la mia
carriera e le mie certificazioni voglio
registrarlo ma per l'amor del cielo a
quella donna serviva aiuto
non sapevo che tipo di parassita avesse
incontrato ma li aveva impiantato
qualcosa internamente sa che non è un
pidocchio e una loro un po più grossa se
tanto c'è proprio l'arco le braccio
rotto che cosa sarebbe successo e si
cerca il kit medico è diventato un
obiettivo del gioco trovare un [ __ ]
kit medico però non è per me e per la
mia amica
no c'è scusatemi ma
cosa sta facendo porco demonio che kakà
che kakà così successo lì
minchia che botta
apri apri apri ma che cazzo vuole ma se
dato fuoco a tutto è andato a fuoco
tutto con la fatto a vedermi 9 questa mi
è piaciuta andato a fuoco tutto andato a
fuoco tutto a me cosa vuoi da me ma va a
cagare va è andata a fuoco tutto pure
tua nonna e a me cosa vuoi da me ma che
palle
che palle no dài dài fate i seri regala
fate i seri perché non sa se da a me io
cosa c'entro io
ma dai ma dai l'ha fatto jima ma
[ __ ] va c'è ma non ho capito io il
giro ha fatto il giro del mondo fa ma
sei scemo ma cosa centro porco demonio
porco le cose dico non vado neanche più
nel fondo teste di culo
il primo anno magari domandarci se
faccio il giro dall'altra parte chi se
ne frega
ma dimmi te o ma non ho fatto niente poi
prodotto non è quale del covers volta lo
schifo se permettete minchia che caga
voi sì sì sì
c'era un beyblade faccio il giro se
permetti grazie ma sai che ti dico
[Musica]
ha suonato il violino per un attimo
dov'è che è andato il fratello di là si
è cagato si è cagato bene si è cagato
l'hanno operato
luca non puoi vedere fa vedere come fa
vedere che sono sotto sei cieco e cieco
e cieco non può saperlo e allora oggi
vedi sei un falso invalido non lo so
oggi vedi o non ci vedi se non ci vedi
non ci vedi non è che se ma [ __ ]
va e dei due ore che faccio così lavora
va a cagà ma dai ma dai ma da erano
madama la facciamo i seri sembra più
cattivo di mio padre quando si incavola
alle vero tom cioè ragionava prima wire
ma dai ma mi prende per il culo ma non
fa le cose seriamente non è che non è
coerente non è coerente o mi vede o non
mi vedi non so come faceva a sapere che
lo 18 come ma come e rosa baiano zitto
l'albero vero fermo e roma poi scendere
ma dai
miri fiumi rifiuto hilton fa elettrico
lo infilo agli sviluppatori e son tre
volte che vedo pietro
gesù mi posso giocare questi giorni qui
che tranquilli giochi tranquilla trama
dell'asse guardian tipo sono tranquillo
sta qui 20esimi ventesima volta dice la
bla bla colpa di dj usa jaks è un hacker
non cracker
io non qualcuno mi spiega cosa devo fare
no veramente ci ho bisogno di capire
perché non capisco sembra stupido
qual è la sua coda ferma sera so cosa
ferma in un vado lì si era associata
ferma qui posso andare le soluzioni
salito nei condotti perfetto il giro
d'affari tra l'altro
ti prego gesù ti prego 53 gg
[Musica]
sono quattro volte che torno in questa
stanza delusi quattro volte 44 sono
quattro volte che entrò nella stessa
stanza
cosa devo fare
non c'è entra nella hall maglio qualche
armadio ma non c'era su un armadio ma
dove asi ciao armadio torri andavo visto
una bomba urla anche me
è
[Musica]
ami deve prima vedere giustamente
entra entra veloce quanto tempo non
entra o vi giuro
vi giuro su dio che ci ha messo un'ora
un'ora per entrare armadio cioè non ha
senso un ora per giuro incredibile
trattenere spicco a casa di trattenere
come si trattiene spin off fermi in siti
liuto opzioni gioco e youth
configurazione comandi no l'altro i da
tastiera schifosi mappatura tasti dove
trattini respiro e non c'è scritto
non c'è scritto come trattengo il
respiro bu vabbè
non ho ben capito come si trattiene il
respiro però va bene tra l'altro mi si e
ricaricata tutta la vita per quale
motivo arcano segue come si trattiene il
tasto destro a ok grazie ragazzi a me
l'avete detto voi non c'è scritto con il
tasto sinistro
ciò nessuno ora rega comunque perché la
mia vita si è ripristinato come è
possibile
ero morto prima se voi adesso mi incazzo
visto che il salvataggio è a 6 anni da
me così io ve lo dico
e andato
no
grazie sara grassi lorenzo grazie duck
per le donazioni gli animi sanno fare la
carbonara non lo so i fornelli ce li
hanno
se il miglior in bocca lupo per tutto
grassi medie crepi il lupo grazie
capitano
no sta facendo il giro di nuovo
cioè si fa sta parte scusatemi
come non sia ripristinato la vita con le
varie c'era un condotto di sopra come no
e vero è scesa di nuovo come ieri era
ricaricata prima lo secondo cui tipo un
secondo fa
comunque io andrei anche stata una
partita ma devo tornare non posso farlo
se non ora quando
adesso gira però a me che giri quando
cioè voglia turno spiega mi sta roba qua
televisore mini adesso sta
[Musica]
ragazzi sto mettendo 6 ore non so se lo
stato è nota ma ci sto mettendo 6 ore 6
ore per arrivare dall'altra parte ci sto
mettendo sei ore
ve lo giuro su dio io non ho mai visto
un gioco così difficile e in qualsiasi
cosi io qualsiasi cosa faccio non va
bene e trattengono respiro e mi metto
sotto la scrivania e 3 mentre e quando
trattengo respiro deve inclinarsi e
quando mi inclino devo ballare la samba
c'è è veramente difficile non ha mai
giocato a rava così un horror più che
altro edificio che magari un casino ma
un horror così difficile è veramente
impossibile perché proprio
difficilissimo non so veramente come
fare c'è giuro
ogni cosa che faccio non va bene tutte
le cose che faccio il nome
saluti da jaeger adwords bravo che hai
colto le chip
penso che uno dei pochi molto dei pochi
c'è forse tutto però grazie insieme a
prezzo a ieri e cioè io non ve lo giuro
non so boh corvo c'è il coro ma neanche
perché se col robot non lo so ragazzo
sono sono depresso abbassa difficoltà ma
non è la difficoltà non è quello è
proprio che che fa del dg limbo
maturavano fatto tra l'altro nel mio
la mia serie vecchiato
due bambini
vieni però ciao entra entra entra
lorenzo in elfico e rino comunque
separabile con di ciccia con quella
vocina con barcellona della prossima
chiara di ciò che chiara grassi rino nel
mio nome in elfico che merda
meno male che mi chiamo lorenzo in
italiano perché è un momento delicato
era un secondo
quello che dovremmo fare s per chinarmi
[Musica]
però c'è chi tira questo è già di qua
già sceso è qui non c'è un salvataggio
neanche a pagarlo cioè che non puoi
salvare la partita
boh dei giri impensabili cioè se
veramente mi premeva più bello il tonfo
elettrico è difficilissimo le parti fate
vedere se riesco ad abbassare veramente
la difficoltà per un attimo perché poi
sembra stronzo
quando dico i miei amici pubblico o non
riesco a fare quella parte ma si è
facile adesso lo state vedendo tutti che
è impossibile st parte difficoltà molto
easy almeno principianti ma neanche
pietro cioè almeno per adesso perché vi
1 st parte infattibile non so cosa fare
vado da qualsiasi parti qualsiasi parte
non va bene
giurano non so cosa fare mi sento v dopo
la rimettono media giu faccio st parte
la rimetto media perché questa parte è
infatti bile ma ho provato di qualsiasi
cosa ho provato queste rossa o salgo
rioni con facciamo incontrare salgo io
nei condotti e lui già aveva giù perché
debbo off ha messo difficoltà
principiante per st parte qui perché
minchia infatti pensa alla difficoltà
massima con la fai
non puoi cesta parte non puoi farla non
mi ricordo quanto ci ho messo il tasto 5
portate nel respiro ma sicuro
alza un pochettino soldi soldi soldi e
in live e non mi vedo cioè se mi vedo ma
sono pigro
vediamo qua c'è un computer wow che
bello se vasto link auci aspettavo
pubblica vediamo c'è un video wow bella
tutti i ragazzi sono una che è stata è
morta
ok e adesso scende del tipo su tutto
non sono nè
adesso era di qua il contrario cioè se
non riescono in principiante mido
all'ippica
stavolta va ancora visto transfer che
penso non sia dovuto al principiante
proprio pensa non mi abbia visto cos'è
il principe in st hai provato almeno
fossero chiari to be sì ci ho provato a
non far scoppiare i tubi e non va la
nuova uguale quella è la cosa che fa
ancora per il e magari sta difficoltà
poi anche camminare non fa niente però
boh non lo so quindi non facciamo più
carte infatti
non c'è tipo le palline da lanciare da
una parte all'altra la map che sarebbe
utile sarebbe fighissimo distrarlo
lanciando delle cose
la tubo bomba mi serve a niente
[Musica]
no
raga in difficoltà principiante e dello
stesso impossibile a casa basta basta vi
prego e insopportabile di pubblico base
alla cassa acustica a sé
minchia questo non è male quasi uso c'è
da piazza proprio casinò bella aria in
principiante e imposte secondo me sta
parte l'anno allora allora mi ritengo
mentre parlo mi ritengo un giocatore
scarso
io di base non c'è gioco proprio a
scazzo è il gioco proprio per gli altri
quindi mi tengo molto scarso
però secondo me questa parte l'hanno
scritta tamale cesta parte e non ai
spazio per muoverti qui secondo me non
per cercare una scusa mi sono scarso
lo ammetto ma sta parte sta parte l'anno
scriptata di merda perché non puoi
nasconderti adesso non puoi far niente
se non morire quindi boh
sì adesso non faccio anche saltare il
cosa ma posso lanciarla transiti
stavolta è quella buona verso la cassa o
la cassa alla lancio mica parte martin
garics 130 e si mette male l'alien
stesso a fare powerbox savior alien
altro che save your internet come
lanciato ai giovani li mortacci tua
madre che è un beyblade bye bye bye bye
non va porca di una [ __ ] ma non è
servita a niente rega
figurati se non passavo mentre passava
lui gesù cristo il tempismo
allora gesù
c'è poi sono anch'io sfigato è però
minchia vantini domanda inquietante non
possa mai passo è avanti a meno avanti
vabbè ma io ho provato tuo ho provato ho
provato tutto provato le casse di
difficoltà i razzi tutto ho provato
tutto non so come la difficoltà è
talmente bassa che lì non sente la cassa
è vero nome è però sente me bo italiana
cassa è fatta per di stare quindi
dovrebbe dovrebbe sentirla c'è con
questa difficoltà la cassa dovrebbe
rimanere a fissarla così tipo per tre
ore così deve fare veramente povero cosa
devo fare più di così no veramente vi
dare i computer in mano viene fatelo e
in po qualsiasi cosa faccio non di far
esplodere tutti noi ha fatti esplodere
stavolta meglio fatti esplodere stavolta
giuro non ho fatto niente
stavolta non ho toccato nulla
linkiamo
prima di chiudere il live che tanto
finiamo tra un'oretta ancora buona
quindi tranqui prima di chiudere la vado
a vedere come avevo fatto è l'ottava
volta che faccio starò molto otto volte
che faccio sta roba infattibile vado
assolutamente a vedermi come l'avevo
fatta perché non esiste sono
curiosissimo boom
fate scaldare becali ne stava lì quindi
questa è la 7 milionesima volta dei
giochi ad alien o e la7 milionesima
volta che prova a fare sta parte
[Musica]
a
porca [ __ ]
se viene avanti ancora ti do un pugno
eccolo
gente che fa apposta conte monio
ormai sono rassegnati
ci sono proprio sono rassegnato a non
riuscito minchia quando ce la farò non
ce la farò ma quando ce la farò
stavolta la prova completamente diversa
abbiamo provato sempre a fare molto
calmi
c'è poi questo fermo tranqui stavolta
corro corpo proprio coro dall'inizio
alla fine
comunque io credo che la difficoltà non
influisca su alien la difficoltà
influisce su gli androidi tipo quanto ti
tolgono di vita perché aliena non è che
cambia niente cambia non è cambiato
nulla dalla modalità normale non cambia
niente tanto la ronda è sempre quella e
ti sente uguale non cambia niente
non vedo quale sia il diverso come la
differenza difficoltà sa che ti levano
di meno gli androidi che va beh è caduta
la testa questo da solo occorro come
gesù
la porno raga perché non ho fatto sempre
stando fermo ma corro corro
eccolo ancora scherzando si adatta
franco hardcore sbattitene le palle gol
buio
hai visto orco demonio
[Applauso]
come dicono qualcosa gli annali
quartiere
a cosa serve a trattenere il respiro
inclinarsi all indietro se vuoi ti
piglia uguale ci dimettiamo con le
scritte inclinati aliyev trattini
respiro [ __ ] il cazzo la cosa lo
fate a fare ste di prenderlo non serve a
niente lo stand del respiro non serve a
niente
grazie serve a niente fare non serve
fare niente non fai niente muori e basta
gli armadietti non servono a niente o se
punta l'armadio sei morto non può
intrattenere respiro né fare niente
bombe e siamo in modalità principiante
tra l'altro guarda come hai fatto no
perché tanto io sono sicuro che non è
che avevo fatto chissà in che modo avevo
fatto così come sto facendo adesso
semplicemente mi era andata bene
cioè non c'è un modo semplicemente ti
deve andare bene che non ti becca ma non
secondo me non c'è un modo per di fare
la cosa credo babù occorso perché è tra
l'altro è l'unica volta in cui sono
andato più più vicino al traguardo e
stavolta ho corso quindi ma non cambia
temi le palle
come si toglierà la scusami usa le bombe
come diversivo e l'ho fatta questa tassa
custi che poi non la sente è scemo senza
solo me minchia o prendi la qui
equipaggi equipaggia la
a
io io giustamente ma qualcosa sta
riusciamo io pensavo facesse il giro
dall'altra parte non faceva che
ovviamente ha fatto giuda mi davo
talmente tante volte che la rifaccio che
sto diventando scemo impossibile trova
non te ne rimane ma non puoi dire
equipaggiare il rilevatore rimane in
mano a prescindere non poi c'è non c'è
un modo per il rilevatore ttb punk e se
non ce l'ha in mano
stavolta no stavolta sono stato scemo io
non avevo pensato un'altra roba
prove di che lo sente la cassa la usiamo
mischia quando la passo sta parte
divento papà
il papa è diventato papà perché è
passato sta parte bergoglio è abbassata
parte qua
il potere è marcatura sbagliato tasto no
hilton faccia il tonfo che non serve a
niente
prova ad accarezzarlo va bene lo
accarezza dopo ciao cos'hai da dirmi che
peccato
questa è quella buona
un po sono un po indeciso a minchia se
il giro tiro e poi esplode h [ __ ]
morirà con i tubi non può morire sono
finisce il gioco sicuro non è che
schiatta ma non c'è un salvataggio nei
salvataggi in studio fanno schifo
no e ci ho pensato anche di buttarlo per
fargli esplode di tubi in faccia però
non non esploderebbero se passa lui
credo non lo so lei dopo ci prova se
muoio tanto muoio quindi riprovo addosso
ciò che vuoi
no e dovrebbe esserci andato è un
calzino quella roba lì sorpresina luce
non c'è un salvataggio la siski siti
hanno visto quale ci è andata giù la
rega queste buone queste buone buone
buona one cioè non salvata ma era qua
tra l'altro dall'altra parte non l'avevo
visto ma va a cagare va sei ore di gioco
inutile cristo sei ore di gioco inutile
per fare una roba ma guarda guarda
guarda dove il deficiente guardalo
ma va no ora per giocasta roba amico
diritto estero che non sapeva niente
però lei ha un bel culo o posso fare le
molotov figo con un'ora e mezza sosta
codice di accesso 702 no devo aprire sta
roba qua si e con ice di accesso quali
si ha accesso
aiuto aiuto di aiuto codici di accesso
2505 c'è scritto 255 sono il papà adesso
hai visto dalla difficoltà non cambia
poi la cambio ma tanto non cambia niente
se non il danno che ti fanno gli android
però non cambia nulla con aliano cosa
faremo
cerca kit me
i quali ci sono tornati a lungo i miei
mi ci è voluto un secolo è giustamente
corro corro chissenefrega tanto non mi
figlia
è scemo e scemo e scemo non è scemo
ma è stato fighissimo per noi
vabbè ho salvato quindi va bene non
corriamo dove devo andare
ora che ho la tessera dove vado a devo
riprendere codice di accessori e lo
rimetto idiota ma riesce a ok perché
devo proprio aprire il file codici 25 10
gol
e poi dei geni minchia se scrivo la
password sul computer di fianco
all'avanguardia ste persone
vabbè la stanza a fianco c'è una porta a
è questa
molto bene grazie ragazzi gentilissima
bravi mente un consiglio tattico che mi
serviva subito salve anche lei non la
vedo bene però visto ali anche stava lì
ricerca punizioni revolver
secondo me se gli metti i video dimette
bizet scappa lui poi meno male che non è
venuto di qua a casa casa casa
velocissimo casa crea dress code monia
parco dai che palle dopo che devo creare
una cassa velocissima che appena la vive
the plan maglie la tira in bocca e va
via
crea l'asta casa veloce taq taq taq
bravo giro con la cassa automatica
gira gira no perché mischia quanto si
muore in sto gioco cristo di dio non ce
ne sono altri così incasinati gesù sta
parte la più difficile di tutto il gioco
fatta questa abbiamo finito finito il
gioco però alieni modalità media grazie
che sono loro 1 giacomo non è vero e lui
sarà il numero uno sono morrissey così
tanto per ragazzi la migrazione la
nazione aliena in modo età media o in
quella facile sempre un pezzo di viale
padova guarda dove il cretino guardalo
qui aspetta che io vada nei posti per
non fermi le palle giusto di qua si va
da qualche parte forse sì
qui è un inferno si
poi mi ricordo che dopo tutto sto
inferno di alien
c'è una parte c'è una parte proprio dove
dove non c'è alien per un po poi c'è una
specie di pausa me lo ricordo questo
perché dopo che il gioco ti ti ti ti
prende il cervello e telo mettetelo
spappola con la tensione c'è proprio una
parte dove non c'è aliena ti sembra
stranissimo che il tuo giochi diceva mi
chiamarono non c'è mai
dopo infatti è molto più easy tra
virgolette per questo motivo non ricordo
lo ricordo perché mi mi ricordo la mia
sensazione di libertà o credibile
e meno male che ha fatto spiderman parco
lemonia
oggi gesù cristo
scegli alla reception
dove devo andare scusatemi che non ho
capito il punto forse devo tornare
indietro ho capito dove devo andare
adesso se mi passa davanti glielo lancio
in la modalità media adesso momento
botteghe ma [ __ ] ha rimbalzato sul
lettino christian reception dottore
indietro marino oppure vado o c'è un
condotto non so dove devo andare
ma quello non è attirato dalla cassa è
un po che cosa questo caso questo che
cazzo questo chi cazzo è questo questo è
scemo e arriva un tizio che corre scemo
a caso a caso la gente corre o ma chi
era ma vajmat ma gente che mi ma
[ __ ] a chi era ma no ma questa
doveri me la sto rivedendo la live 10
secondi ritardano chi è chi era questo
ma siete scemi
uno che corre poi ti sembra il momento
di correre tra l'altro o deficienti un
deficiente
non so chi sia una 11 1 che correva poi
correva senza guardare avanti body bo in
skyrim il corrose chicca chi era quello
ma perché i cammini accovacciato se mi
metto in piedi quello mi sbrana al
cervello già neo poco che poi non è che
babbo c'era uno che corre va tutto
storto cevo tutto scemo e non ho capito
questa parte non l'ho capita ve lo giuro
non ho capito cosa sia successo
non ho capito però va bene
no no non mi riferì mente mi rifiuto
alle volte non capisco da dove che era
il tipo scusami non era qua
dov'era il morto che poi sono andato da
lui creata tra via
no no ma veramente c'è con la roba di
non l'ho capito ieri non è che non è che
dico se l'è preso alien o aliena preso
me non ho ci siamo ci siamo dati una
testata io e lui io quel tipo ci siamo
dati una testata in bocca lui mi ha
ucciso poi sarà morto da alieno era
troppo tardi cioè proprio le le comiche
è diventato il cabaret così picchia era
quello non li ha sentiti la bestia gli
spari non lo dico io lo vedo
è vero che insegna a 22 persone che
corrono 2 mongoloidi 2 mongolo ecco vedi
che dallo stare si stanno avvicinando
non all'altro a chi è chi è
novi giurano quest'anno non ho capito
chi è quel tizio arriva da live
strutturata
no
qualcuno ti scorre da qualche [ __ ] c'è
gente pensa così
ma dai ma dai ma dai ma dai gli angolini
delle cose
rilanciamo il casinò così aliena andava
di fare faceva fuori tutti ma basta che
ali al di veda ma bravi andate
esattamente anche voi dove c'è quel
bordello li bravi ma se non è che posso
non solo con me porca [ __ ] questo agli
arti per terra
minchia avanti stiamo calo
no
aliens c successo solo quando io cammino
mi sente gli altri non li sento
vabbè parte che mi sa che qua dietro poi
non c'è un punto dove salvare neanche
per sbaglio
eccolo c'è gente stranissima kebo usala
revolver e gli atti lo attivi da allora
hai ragione però se l'uso la revolver
loro mi sparano poi non ho tanta vita
cioè non ne ho proprio visti mi
riguardano sono morto col di prima
abbiamo guardato ero morto hanno fatto
in tempo a far niente
abbiamo professionale procedura di
installazione su s dai dai
no comunque a difficoltà scusatemi c'e
ragione
perdonatemi difficoltà sorry sorry l'ho
cambiata è stato non cambiava niente
perché agli e non cambia non è più
facile da prevedere
penso che tutto questa cosa che si
affaccia che sto facendo facchetti
faccia veramente casinò e che ali entro
tre secondi qua 21 no che sarà dunque
non è servito a niente di diminuire la
difficoltà prima questo è poco ma sicuro
ciao
ciao barca trottola
ciao ma con l'android gli liberati se
temi schio vi ho dato la vita voi mi
obbedite adesso teste di culo ma non mi
sa che non mi avvilisco se però vado non
va bene un vado ad almeno non c'e alien
e devo ad attivare il computer che c'è
davanti a quel morto immaginano è sì sì
non tornare indietro bravo esattamente
così
[Musica]
comunque non ho capito se questi se gli
androidi puoi farli fuori o no in bocca
pittore successo dai dai dai dai
sui diritti da amministratore wow
la ministra non si sente è identico
è quanto cosa scappa passando per la
reception di san cristóbal ok e posso
entrare nei condotti no posso riservare
la partita posso visse posso riservare
la partita si matura usa il tonfo per
gli android ecco questo è già un ottimo
consiglio perché tanto non mi ha toccato
cioè finché si parli android ancora in
gol
che casino dial sono mi può sentire
queste cammino passa lì e lo vede non lo
uccide non la ndrina l'android non lo
uccide perché l'androide non è umano
uccide solo di un solo meucci da quel
presente schifoso capito
ma è l'io a noli c'è un tizio ok filiali
e non musiche finché c'è quel tizio
davanti a sono coperto perché se alinari
va a mazza lui in teoria ecco ma viene
da me tipo ii e viene male ma va dominio
eccolo eccolo questo volevo molto bene
tipo più che alla coda di freddo cioè
etanolo
devo tornare dove scappa passando per
non è semplice quindi qua quella
reception
gli androidi poi uccidere ma ci metti un
botto ok
intanto è caduta una lattina bibite
gratis limite gratis per l'umano
sfortunato
ma voi la birra è una caduta menica te
ti levi dalle palle
[Musica]
siamo qui guardiamo la partita c'è
l'inter c'è la juve guardiamola la
partita no con comodo è prendo il
biglietto quando vince il mio numero
passo io ho sentito questa pianta primo
per noi a [ __ ] sei fermo immobile come
se non esistessi
[Musica]
adesso non posso passare di qua perché
se non mi esplodono i tubi che non ho
fatto esplodere prima offrirgli un caffè
e no è la birra è caduta al alien punto
extra stop work vedete che non è
cambiato ogni ora ricambiato le sue
difficoltà e vedete che non è cambiato
niente di difficoltà di alien perché non
la difficoltà non influenza aliena ma
solo gli androidi è la gente che è una
stronzata in realtà perché il gioco si
basa su alcuni potrebbe dovrebbe
diminuire ali ma fa niente
dove dove dopo ma le station era quella
comunque dove che devo andare lega non
devo passare di qua ok c'è ragione
devo tornare indietro
dove devo andare vorrei tanto salvato
quindi va bene però dove devo andare
esattamente la reception
ma la lezione su questa scappa passando
per la reception equa questa essenza
centrale elettrico pure in fondo a
destra
porca [ __ ] non è che salvato
ok alla da solo forse di qua
giusto
mi piace come si sporge di tre metri
[Applauso]
dai dai
con tornare indietro non tornare
indietro te possino
dai che ci arrivi dai tu
dai ok
ma
eccellente brutta e questa la porta exit
ex it exit uscita uscita scritto exit
all
alla tuba
[Musica]
ci sono pensa che curò esploso tutto nel
momento in cui scappa vero guar grazie
mille del consiglio perché veramente se
non mi ha visitato consiglio non avrei
mica fatto sarei rimasto qua grazie di
avermi scritto scappano a seriamente
l'orco demonio
e diventato un climbing simulator trave
che si stacca tra 32 19 esploso moon
qualcosa
che cos'è sta roba qua è affatto un
corto circuito del mito
no mi ricordo
raffica di certo che se non è morto con
quell'esclusione non muore mai più
c'è veramente se non è morto adesso me
lo ricordo mela ricorsi mi ricordavo che
esplodeva ma me lo sono ricordato tre
secondi prima che esplodesse perché
dicevo va bene un po uccidermi quindi
qualcosa dovrà succedere è successo
e vero la vita aumenta e diminuisce è
aumentata di nuovo la mia vita a caso e
poi ri diminuisce o non capisco tanto va
beh non serve a niente adesso se riesco
a trovare dalla la fiamma ossidrica so
come va beh come prendere il medico
nuovo ve l'ho detto dai l'ultima
mezz'ora di live facciamo le cose fatte
bene posso corner e travi 2 vedi torcia
ioni necessaria questo è quello che
vostra madre pensa che accada quando usi
fornelli
no questo è quello che accade quando si
voleva a me succede esattamente questo
non è morso potrebbe ovvio che non è
morto torno a taylor con le scorte
mediche
amici ha dato tutto a fuoco figo sono
stato io trovo un accesso alternativo
ricordati di salvare vero e non ci sono
così di salvataggio
mi piace in contatti perché non ti può
succedere niente in teoria nicole ma
l'ho detto è
infatti c'è gente so dove
ma che grazie mackerras dalai le fai
ogni giorno no le faccio tutti i lunedì
e tutti i giovedì dalle 9 alle 11 e
mezza due ore e mezza di lancome alle 9
il lunedì e alle 9 il giovedì ce l'hai
misero piano perché devo sistemare tutto
io stavo a perché se un uomo davanti
trovati cilindro di compressione a il
famosissimo cilindro di compressione
non sapevo si trovasse anche nelle navi
ciao gente posso provare a sparargli in
faccia così giusto per la voglia di
provare a farlo poi nel caso ricarico il
salvataggio anche che mira brutta
perfetto salve da hera per divertirmi
era per enjoyment poi è ovvio che anzi
sapete che vi dico
sapete che vi dico vi dico questo ciao
bravi bravi sparate bravissimi
complimenti continuato a sparare bravi
bravi ragazzi complimenti
ho invitato un amico alla vostra festa
si chiama vanessa quinti a li ha fatti
fuori nanosecondo
so good bravi ragazzi complimenti siete
proprio brand sede proprio delle brave
persone
e chissà che questa in realtà era per
arrivare qua quindi io ho usato il
metodo alternativo luciano android è
morto che simpatico crostali enel
rendilo tuo schiavo ma credo sia il
contrario in realtà credo è per carità
magari sta gente c'è anche un buon loot
vabbè per la luce se riesco posso
camminare e mica mi viene il mal di
schiena solo non capiva già scala
bene stiamo andando torna taylor e vabbè
ma non c'è un obiettivo è questo
flachi des a restare
tweakweek ufficiale questa deve fare lei
perché vanessa però non accede al
terminale sei stato un po cattivo con
quelli da anche secondo me mi sa che non
ho sbagliato
di sicuro non mi metto ad ascoltare una
nota audio sul computer in questo
momento o cena altre
deciditi cosa stai facendo
ce ne andiamo fuori dalle palle o siamo
qui ancora due tre ore ha portato tra
tra un modo proprio il portellone
deposito è tesserato accesso ma dimmi te
non a volumi marca vacca usa l'androide
di assistenza tipo quelli che ci sono
l'ikea ti dicono allo scaffale b equa ok
android di assistenza ma che forse devo
andare
aspettami salvarne devo andare su quella
scala e poi tornare giù però prendo
prima sto belgi che penso sia l'attesa
leggere
non so se salvare in questo momento è
stata la cosa più giusta che io abbia
mai fatto in tutta la mia vita perché
c'era linke cioè ecco in questo caso ad
esempio perché se alien mi avesse visto
io e si salvato la partita subito dopo
c'è il caricato un salvataggio dove anni
e mi ammazzava sempre avevo finito di
giocare e non me lo rifacevo ad acta
cavo da questo dico se ne vado fino qua
ex nelle descrizioni script live
domenicali è vero
[Applauso]
correggo bravo grazie che mai detto
penso che l'android di assistenza sia al
piano di sopra comunque poi dopo che
l'attivo uscendo sicuro la minchia
ci presentiamo un po di più
beppe bè non poteva mettere le porte
normali tipo in amnesia o sono morto
sono morto sono morto di asfissia
asfissia nord ok ok resetta la posizione
di alien ogni volta no perché se non
aveva senso quindi se a lille mista un
millimetro salvo la partita posso di
caricare sulla pace dopo non mi tocca no
non posso darvi sempre perché miss
correggiano in faccia quindi devo
trovare l'android a eccolo qua mi scusi
mi dice dove sono gli scaffali quelli
per le sedie ripristina la corrente
io devo fare sto gioco
e anche questo pensava la partita qua
minchia la metro di milano ma non come
riavvio la corrente ma scusatemi perché
qua succede questa cosa ci sono delle
spore in sostanza e vabbè tanto non può
entrare lì dentro
ma dov'è qui sotto
non ho capito dove dove il tizio prove
temi che è finito con me entrò in quella
ragazza temi la mano dove è il commento
di quella stanza lì come riavvio
l'elettricità
immagino che per riavviare l'elettricità
io debba immagino che per attivare
l'elettricità io debba entrare in quella
stanza però è piena di spore come entrò
nella stanza delle spore c'è spore passa
brasiliano che trova a via toledo dove
poter come entro per favore della stanza
di prima devi cercare qualcosa non
c'entri facili non no complimenti grazie
ragazzi molto gentile c'è veramente
degli aiuti assurdi riprende la maschera
antigas scopare grazie x ray a napoli
non ricordo questa parte dovevi passare
lunghi corridoi buonanotte favino litro
nascerà da brogli
marley ha preso vabbè tanto sono sempre
lì ad evitare una maschera antica tra di
respiro intrigo e poi non lo so
d'orsi trovare una maschera antigas e
ditemi come dove la trovo il bel cielo
ma non mi fa aprire la stanza pietro è
inutile la porta di sotto
l'ultima non capire dove sta parte
scendi scendi scendi scendi comunque
alien non al naso tipo voldemort che lui
sarebbe immune a quella stanza lì è
rimasto c'è scritto qualcosa sul
computer li prende la maschera antigas e
dovendo st
se ci fosse qualche inizio
devo tirare android piano di sotto
l'orlo e non c'è l'elettricità rega
manca la corrente non va la corrente
sono se non avrei già fatto che non si
apra questa porca [ __ ] che ansia che
ansia dietro l'android c'è la maschera
siete sicuri
vabbè
ma proviamo dai
eni gas e luce
e facciamo un'altra roba aspetta cassa
acustica
non è bene
lanciamo dovrebbe lanciarlo nella stanza
sono riusciti a lanciarlo fuori ma
neanche centrare la porta che
grossissima devo entrare là dentro non
so come si entra giuro giusto problema a
traquillo prove adesso
porca [ __ ]
allora faceva corrente a ripristinare
quindi no devo trovare la maschera
antigas e le maschere antigas
where he is it home 58 qua molto bene la
maschera stato che cela android ma non è
vero che ho visto non c'è
un metallo
ma [ __ ] ma sono entrambi invece il
condotto che anche cosa se che condotto
inutile questo pensavo di portarsi in
un'altra stanza
dietro l'androide negli scaffali ma dove
lo vedo solite tutti era lo scemo io
la maschera non la trovi in questa parte
ma più avanti non ti serve per entrare
in quella stanza va bene come entry
quella stanza tale senso non ti serve
proprio per andare avanti e che devo fà
ciao
dai che palle
perché devo stare sei ore ad aspettare
che sto demente l'altro mi ha visto lo
ha fatto a vedermi ma scegliere gli
occhi o non ce l'hai
questa questa ve la voglio vedere
scusami fammi vedere come vuoi prendermi
c'è allora ciglia gli occhi dove trovate
vabbè come ripristino la corrente di ma
come come allora può entrare nei
condotti e non sapevo lo sapevo park a
[ __ ] devo ridare la corrente attivare
l'androide va a me come era attivo la
corrente come la reattivo la corrente mi
piace un sacco la maglietta che vi
addosso grazie a dove ho sparato
va bene era pone
farei volentieri se riuscissi anche a
solo a togliermi da qua a dottore dovevo
sparato capito ho capito ho capito molto
molto molto molto easy easy un cazzo
cassa acustica dai no tav tac che qui
tai però scendi premier quindi dovevo
sparato dove c'era la gente dove c'era
la gente dove c'era la che va bene ho
capito
impossibile ma ci proviamo
beh che scende
ma c'è ancora un tipo in piedi come
possibile come dicevano farei il sacco
di video su youtube dicevano e quindi
qua cioè teoricamente sei morto però
facciamo finta di nemici ed attuali
nella sopra va beh devo trovare il modo
di accendere la corrente cremona tempo a
destra a vedi che ci sono le scale
[Musica]
mi sa che si sono attaccati lui e col
tizi vista la musica che è cambiato
[Musica]
sono attaccati
siamo messi
da qualche parte comunque qui aggiunge
la corrente fisso
dico che c'è uno android è morto
sa che è successo la quale la corrente
vede puoi vedere che sia fatto
centobuchi
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] l'avevo visto mari ma perché
vivi da una bottiglia di vetro e perché
no una scusa ma cosa ci avete contro le
bottiglie di vetro anche l'altra volta
avete chiesto una bottiglia di vetro ma
che non posso bere dalle bottiglie di
vetro che io non ho capito se avete
avuto le bottiglie di vetro
[Musica]
è però cerco pure il modo di ha
abbastanza sono stanca guarda la mia
dato live che mi che mi tira su baci
grazie sarà grazie mattina anche grazie
mano e le casse paolo e grazie
non ti vorrei di tirarmi su però la
gente muore
la mia ricerca comunque grazie mille
molto gentile comunque non ho capito
dove dovrebbe stare corrente che farmi
giro di su
vv c'è una scala questa potrebbe essere
molto buoni dov'è lo zio non c'è
[Musica]
peso di qua dicendo dovrei riuscire a
trovare grazie dardan per riuscire a
trovare in un secondo la corrente se dio
vuole
mi ha fatto veramente un giro
incredibile è morto quello lì per
sicurezza semantica se non è lì in mezzo
dove c'è sta gente qua dove c'era sono
né qua giuro che non ho idea di dove
possa essere
questa no come riattivo la corrente raga
batterie per la torcia questo ci aveva
ottimi
e manco qua la corrente
l'evento aspetta ha celebrato
mi chiama sono andato ovunque dove
corrente regalo
santo mongoloide veramente visto tutti i
costi non ne manca neanche uno il
condotto ad ora ne che dovevano riparare
sto a fare qua tanto salvo
condotto non mi porta da quella parte lì
niente
l'indicatore ti indica la direzione per
arrivare
non è vero
l'indicatore indica dove alien più o
meno
no non mi sbaglio io comunque
l'indicatore che io sappia ti indica
l'obiettivo ma non quello che devi fare
per raggiungerlo c'è chi indica che devi
accendere l'androide ma non ti indica
dove stando
mi ha fatto ritornare qua scusa caso
scemo
seguendo sta a fare l'affare mi porta
qui a via l'androide ma sarei stronzo
allora obiettivo aggiornato
se un ora che che stai a di
ma sembra ora che che devo attivare
andrà forse non ancora avviato
l'obiettivo solo per quel motivo no mi
chiamo non dire che scelta
e qua
scusa scusatemi
[Musica]
scusatemi no no adesso non semi
ricercatori pista vapore oppure mi dice
che l'obiettivo è qua
una mano amici visto che sono sei ore
che ci provo ma come si avvia la
corrente come l'avvio
[Musica]
torna nella stanza dove essere datome
qua
questo
fan
c'era un po ma cusco come ho fatto a non
vederlo prima come ho fatto a non
vederlo prima mi sto gioco se ti perdi
un oggetto maledetto per diritto
ora che ho questa roba qua vado al piano
di sopra possa aprire la porta si però
mica lega non avevo visto
vi giuro cioè se gioco se ti perdi un
micro cosa e per finito di vivere
quindi qua non ci passo per passo in
quella sopra corretto
l'attrice la musica e ancora non ho
capito dove dovrebbe stare a lungo
abbiamo ma io controllo sempre bene
senza che ci sono veramente troppi posti
stato enorme quindi non è neanche colpa
mia
no come ok sei ore grazie leonardo molto
gentile grazie leonardo detto che
leonardo ha proprio questa porta lo
faccio per te lo faccio per voi grazie
martina grazie e giacomo che è servita
stavolta
da pezzi di metallo niente di che vamos
[Musica]
web carino
vai dimmi dove sono i mobili quelli da
montare ciao ciao piacere sono fa vigili
facci video dammi la mano
sì ma stai calma all'aja io lo seguo
lol
ayew lo devo seguire va bene non puoi
prendermelo dopo i toni sa i codici
molto bene a 6323 ricordiamoci bye bye
la donna che bordello
tutto ciò se n'è andato ma più o meno
ecco qui di compressione si trova grazie
cioè io porca [ __ ] che è successo ma no
ma dai ma com
dai che palle ma [ __ ] dai raga mi
è scappata però porca vacca dai dopo due
ore mi chiamo io perché quello sempre da
una scossetta visto
gaga leva mezzora trascorsa è morto come
le mosche
cioè non rip android replay oh certo
anzi ri lei anche se va bene
ma tipo ci parlano anche a distanza se
tifoso anche sto qua no
dai vieni nuova veloci
ma non puoi di salvare come ciao gabri
grazie mille per la donazione apri
veloce schifoso essere bene non passiamo
vicino alle cose che possono portare il
mio sistema nervoso quindi andiamo
avanti attraverso i condotti ad esempio
ma no
il condotto non va da nessuna parte mai
una gioia ecco qui alla fine di questa
fine ad evo devo minchia vabbè il suo
oroscopo non girava male se non girava
bene valori e vado
ok adesso di qua
apro film base a quello che schiacci
molto chiaro adesso
a puoi passare anche esterno ma che
palle
il cilindro di compressione si trova
ma
no
e questo credo allora che non sto
capendo aiutatemi cosa sta succedendo
dove sto schifo di cilindro dove trova
il cilindro di compressione qua è questo
allora scusami ma dove non l'ho visto
avanti
ma eccolo a cagare ok sostituiamo ci
sostituiamo l'asta meno lavori sono resi
però ragazzi non le vedo le lobby del
pieno di colle ha tra l'altro
l'elettricità da tra farsi [ __ ]
potevo provare a folgorare alien
se qualcuno ci ha mai pensato e dal 2014
che ti seguono attrazione tra l'altro
grazie dio grazie anche a martina va
bene domani di fare colazione
pensando al tempo alle grazie mister ti
fai salvare che voglio chiudere grazie
st e stata veramente difficile questa
parte sta la i di oggi si gesù cristo
mammamia rega oggi per fare le robe è
stato un casino un casino però figo va
bene dai basta spero che vi sia piaciuto
continuiamo lunedì prossimo con la live
di allison action e ci vediamo domani
con un prossimo video che vi sia
piaciuto ma solito ragazzi grazie per
aver seguito la dai
gentilissimi saremo più meramente a
gioco e andiamo a spaccare andiamo a
finirlo
spero vi sia piaciuto cosi se il video è
piaciuto al momento invece ancora
rischio cioè quindi la descrizione senza
doversi di sky tree è micidiale